it's lovely to see you here today for
half of a Yellow Sun now tell me what it
was about the novel that attracted here
to adapt it for the big screen I just
fell in love with the characters among
the first time I read the book I loved
the sisters or Lana and Carina I loved
ordaining boo boo boo
mama the very irritable or brilliant
mama
or the enables mother and I loved the
stories and it was also it was said part
of the was said during the Nigerian
civil war which was when I was born in a
war that I has had a great fascination
for me since I was a child and she was a
combination of the fact that you know
you had this great love story well love
stories and and the war and I thought I
want to make this into a movie my baby
was in very good hands because the
director is a friend and somebody who's
Walker admire and now that I've seen the
film it's quite surreal but it's also
very moving to see this just wonderfully
talented actors opening their mouths and
and what comes out but the sentence is I
made up it's actually quite fantastic
what I loved about the novel javi
Ellison is that it's such a universal
story it's a love story and both the two
glamorous twin sisters and sit in quite
a surprising setting as you can very
glamorous prosperous setting which is
not people normally expect to see from
Africa and I just I fell in love with
the story because I could identify with
the kind of surprising choices the women
were making and because the book has
appealed to women across the board we
felt as an opportunity to tell a very
strong story that's firmly rooted in
Nigeria but has universal themes that
think appeal to audiences across the
world was very interesting to go from
Nigeria and Ana film about some of the
conflict there
and and go straight and to you know fly
over to Louisiana to discuss you know a
film that you know to be in a film that
also develops it discusses conflicts
that involved Nigeria involved in the
slave trade involved that exact area you
know the Nigeria and the Bight of Benin
around there which is where we were
shooting in calibre which is why I
visited you know the the slave museums
there before I left and so the two
projects are they're very different had
certain connections it was to challenge
I believe got me involved I think he did
see now it's in production I was in and
but you know there suggested it to be be
agreed and so I was blown out to be a
part of the three part of the crowd my
characters are Chioma and I was is
loosely based on Christopher kickball a
poet who basically put down his pen and
went from picked up a gun went for for
what he believed in unfortunately played
with his life why is it timely I suppose
right now Africa has moved out of past
very much and looking into the future
we're trying to iron our tribal lines so
this shows us what tribalism and sort of
that deep belief in that can do in terms
of dividing us I think it's I think it's
really important for Africa as a as a
continent to start thinking about a way
forward and past this
I played mama Chiyo tell each of those
characters mother and she was a tough
woman but really at the heart of it all
was the great love she had for her son
and trying to protect him and she was in
larious at the end of the day I think in
the film although she started out as a
cantankerous character you really could
see through her humanity and she's just
like every other loving concerned mother
and she made up with her daughter-in-law
other
and actually suggested that Hasan should
indeed carry out the wedding so it was a
very good character for me to play I
could sink my teeth into it I could
channel my migrant one of my
grandmother's hot smoke and
troublemaking woman that she was so it
was fun it was great fun I felt that um
Tandy was just attracted to the strength
of the parent the parts of Alana and
Kenny neither twin sisters are very
unusually strong rules for women and
Tandy responded to immediately when she
read it I think she saw a real
opportunity to do a range of emotional
film and she's very pleased with the
film she's been kind enough to say it's
one of the best performances ever given
which i think is true and similarly with
chewer tale I think he saw there's of
just a very substantial role and it's a
story that's very close to his heart and
it's close his own family's experiences
I'm just proud to be part of it I mean
as an actor I am british-born but you
know I consider myself African so being
part of anything that advances African
anyway he's always a dream really what
was the experience like a filming for
you it was wonderful an extraordinary
and sad and I'm very hard nigeria's
difficult plays Kalla boys were
beautiful at the same time very
problematic politically and culturally
and there's a lot of poverty around so
you in an environment which isn't really
it doesn't always feel akin to the world
of filmmaking and yet you're there it's
making a film about these people
about Nigeria rather than the people
about Nigeria and its independence and
when it flourished and I think that's
what we don't see that's what we do see
in this film is Nigeria when it did
flourish before the Biafra war and
actually the first images that
journalists came out with was from the
vehicle war so we have this warped
vision of Africa back here the pictures
that came from that and actually we
don't see this side which is a sleeve
very wealthy very vibrant alive and of
course then we go into the Civil War
which is a very very testing time it was
an incredibly tough shoot but I loved
every single moment of it and I found
from the very first day of the shoot
that I just I just felt completely at
home on a set I just it was just where I
wanted to be I loved working with the
actors it was great working with chortle
Ejiofor and Tandy Newton and John boyega
and Joseph Moore I had a great cast
anika Noni Rose actually I had a
wonderful wonderful cast
I just felt lucky every day I woke up
doing during the shoot
he mentioned challenges I believe there
were TV for a bit probably on the street
weren't they
yeah Tandy hat I thought I had time for
a few other members of my casts
contracted typhoid
when it first happened I panicked and
then after a few days when people were
sometimes getting typhoid and malaria at
the same time became some kind of
gallows humor that bonded everyone in
the crew and and we didn't actually take
a single day off I mean it was either
some kind of insane adrenaline just
pumping through our veins and and we we
made it we made it I think I escaped
apart from a lot of mosquito bites and a
lot of nights sort of humid ly itching
away and trying to get some sleep I was
I did all right actually I was one of
the lucky ones to survive that that part
of it so I know I came out relatively
scot-free well the high I suppose is you
know whatever they say action and you're
working with such great people the low
would be getting a touch of malaria a
little bit of typhoid as well and yeah
what it was you know it was it was part
of the experience he had the time you
think oh god I don't want to be dealing
with this but now I'm just happy it
makes for a good story telling I guess
what are you going to take from this
film onto your next project
um well I've actually just shot an 8
part drama series on TV base in Lagos
and and now the top shoot but it was
nothing as tough as half of a Yellow Sun
and and so when my producer day in Lagos
was panicking I just said listen this is
easy just take it easy it's fine you
know so so that you know it was like you
know director my first movie was also
like going to like some really
excruciating ly hard film school and I'm
really glad for it
you